well guten tag it's silverette again and
it's time to wrap up this
preparation thingy before i start the
real deal so
let's do this
so
um
you
so
so yeah we're getting there i mean this
episode i actually did quite a lot of
work i didn't expect me to do this much
so i've got
the basics of the rock work done and the
reason why i'm adding all that rock work
is that i'm actually not going to use
the actual in-game terraforming for the
mountain but it'll exist out of just
custom scenery rocks the only reason why
i did make that little mountain
is just to have a simple guideline of
where the mountain should be and where
the coaster should go and where i should
have tunnels etc
so now that i got that out of the way i
can start doing the actual work and make
this thing look good
so
i'm going to do that next episode so
let's get to that then